all right bmac what's going on Mark B
where you from or where'd you grow up um
so I was born I was born on the east
coast in Maryland um you know my mom was
going to Howard University so she had us
out there in DC um but I came up in the
West San Francisco Mission District 16th
of Mission to be exact you know so if
you know about San Francisco and the
Mission District you know 16th of the
mission is probably
one of the places where you don't want
to go if you don't not supposed to be
there you know so yeah that's where made
my made my name you know and that's
where a lot of people know me from um
but being from the East and the West you
know it just helped me be who I am from
a real dot connector you know your mom
your mom was good yeah my mom's good
yeah what was your dad honestly you know
what's crazy my dad I never ever met him
I've only seen him one time and that's
in a picture and that's with my older
sister wow yeah yeah yeah so it's a
common story though yeah but I you know
even though it's a common story I don't
take it as
uh like it doesn't affect me you know
people like like to use that as excuse
oh I never had a dad to me just is what
it is my mom was my mom and my dad you
know is what it is what was your
relationship like with your mom it's
good yeah it um I would say coming up
you know was Rocky just because I I was
so much into the streets but as I got
older and she started to kind of just
realized you know and I mean he's a man
then it just kind of just became easier
like we text each other all the time
um last last time I was locked up [__]
she was the only one that came and visit
so you know so you know it's like yeah
she gets you she got me yeah she
definitely got me if I call her she got
me yeah yeah Y and if she calls me I got
her so that's great what kind of what
kind of trouble were the streets getting
you into um as a kid oh shoot
honestly always weed to be honest that's
the craziest thing from I always caught
weed cases whether it's small weed cases
big weed cases um that's what I was
always known for you know always known
for and the the younger crowd is
probably forgetting or it doesn't even
realize that weed was illegal yeah weed
was illegal right very illegal and um at
one point in a lot of these states that
it's legal now is the states that I
really made a name in you know um from
Colorado be way before it was legal
um DC Maryland Florida Texas I mean
these were all my stomping grounds you
know Collinsville Illinois um yeah we
really made a big big name as far as the
that weed movement went you know people
when you talk about truckloads we were
doing truckloads 10 years ago weed was
as serious an offense as as as crack or
anything else MH yep definitely
especially if you talking about the
South if you want to go into the D the
like those there the Virginia and stuff
oh man you you're really talking big
time talking big money you I mention
that cuz now weed is like you know it's
like bubble gum yeah it's nothing now
yeah yeah it's crazy y mhm yeah like
even um what so I actually caught a case
in Illinois a long time ago and because
it became
legal uh it was what two years ago they
had they pulled me over they pulled up
the case it was 10 years they actually
put me on house arrest for this case and
what uh Collins Illinois did they were
like a man it's legal now we really
can't do anything to him now just you
know statue statute limitations yeah
just let him go yeah but that was
cool where where's Collinsville uh it's
right outside of St Louis okay yeah yeah
I'm I'm Chicago boy but I don't know
Collinsville yeah that's the crazy thing
me either so we're coming from Colorado
I'm coming from Colorado and um what
happened was as soon as we got outside
of St Louis the police just pulled us
over and this this is one of the crazy
stories he pulls this over and he says
oh you guys have it was me and my boy
says you guys have dreads you guys must
be from Illinois uh St Louis and they're
like yo with St Louis guys come over
here they do nothing to cause trouble
we're like yo we know nothing about St
Louis this this this like and he says
well we're going have to pull the dogs
out okay pull the dogs out they pull the
Dogs Out the dog doesn't alert this is
probably this is probably one of my very
first drug traing cases dog doesn't
alert and um what the cop actually does
is he takes the dog literally takes the
dog and throws him into the window yeah
yeah he throws him into the passenger
window and he's like yeah he has to
smell something I'm like no way yo and
I'm talking about these we're in the
middle of the woods these cops are
chewing um they're chewing no not
chewing tobacco they're chewing uh
toothbrushes like they're literally
chewing toothbrushes we're in the middle
of the woods me and my boy like oh my
goodness this is going to be bad the
cops are chewing toothbrushes yeah they
had toothbrushes in their mouth chewing
toothbrushes literally yeah and they
were like yeah and so from there he just
pops the trunk he just goes I'm like
hold up how he Pop the trunk from
throwing the dog in the window they were
certainly you were oh yeah and there
they go they find two suitcases full of
you know a weed and yeah that was one of
my early early early trafficking days um
trafficking cases and yeah that was bad
and col Illinois is weird that's one of
those jails where they put you in the
black and white jumpsuits like life you
know the movie Life oh you're in the
black and white jumpsuits and it's yeah
separate the black guys the white guys
everybody gots separated oh yeah it was
crazy how old were you um that happened
when I think I was 18 yeah yeah I was
about 18 yeah yeah how long are you
selling or dealing oh I probably been
selling weed all my life um I'd say
probably
since I've been smoking weed since fifth
grade put it like that I'm 35 years old
never stopped
um but I probably been selling weed
since middle school yeah yeah selling
pounds High School school for sure yeah
and then once out of high school we get
into the you go from the the Greyhounds
to the to the am tracks to the to the
planes to the
trucks your mom stuck by you the whole
time yeah well no I wouldn't say that
because
um the only time she stuck by me cuz a
lot of times she didn't know what was
going on so like I would catch cases a
lot of time I I would have money so you
know and I always lived in my own since
I was 17 so um I catch a case we have
money I make sure I get the baill like
so a lot of these things she wouldn't
even know the the time when she really
found out is when I caught the case um
going to Maryland and this is how I got
you know my no ankle here you know and
um so what what happened to your ankle
you you want to tell that story Yeah
Yeah so basically which is crazy you got
to watch out who you uh friends with who
you deal with for sure um so I was I had
a uh a nice solid team a females um guys
a whole solid team over there in
Maryland um working with me and um so
I'm in San Francisco I usually I rarely
have to come to Maryland so to do what I
have to do you know the the pounds get
there the money gets back that that's
all that matters to me you know how
would you have somebody
transported those days for the Maryland
days that's when that would have been
the am TRS in the Greyhound days yep we
were flooding the amra and Greyhounds
you had you had somebody that would
escort it yeah yeah you you pay you get
a couple girls from San Francisco you
know la like Lauren surrounding
cities coule from surrounding cities you
pay them
$1,000 per suitcase it doesn't matter
how how much is in there right what's in
there go you know and hey and they'll go
with four suitcases you know per yeah
and it's cool they put it up under and
just ride it on out that's great yeah
and then um but yeah that would that
would have been the you know the Amtrak
days and uh so I'm in San Francisco
we're just I'm just kicking it and I get
a phone call one day that uh one of my
partners out there he's got an ear
infection so I'm okay ear infection cool
he has to do surgery it doesn't really
bother me and um but the very next day
my phone's blowing up phone's blowing up
pham's blowing up and you know the East
Coast they're they're 3 hours ahead so
I'm still asleep and when I find answer
my phone they say Hey Jake actually died
from the surgery and I'm like whoa oh my
goodness so now it kind of made me have
to rush to go you know I wanted to hurry
up try to make his funeral and so this
how God works too as well so first thing
I did was I bought an amtr ticket to try
to get back fast I bought an Amtrak
ticket and um because it was so all a
sudden the girl I was dealing with I end
up missing the Amtrak that next day but
which is very very crazy that same amtr
if you look it up right now it actually
crashed that was the amtr that crashed
in San Francisco yeah it crashed yeah
that same exact am Track ticket that I
bought actually crashed people die yeah
people died and everything mhm yeah that
was one that derailed and people
actually died and so I was like whoa
okay but um so I end up taking the
Greyhound and so this is like a three
now end up being a three-day trip so I
actually missed the funeral but I'm
still going to get down there um I get
down there and I I end up driving around
5 it's probably
like not 5:00 a.m. probably like 3:00 4:
a.m. and the girls picked me up from the
Greyhound this is way up in like um they
picked me up from Baltimore so we're
riding from Baltimore
to uh the part of Maryland that um where
where the stash houses were at and this
is like a probably a 45 minute ride
there's another girl who's also in the
passenger seat she's like playing sleep
like she's like playing like she's like
kind of playing like she you know she's
not sleep but she's playing sleep and
it's weird so I'm already noticing all
the weird stuff from the back seat and
as we pull up to the uh to the house
there's these guys sitting in the in the
driveway um it's it's a big apartment
building they're sitting in the uh
they're sitting in the apartment
building they have their lights on but
as soon as we pull up they cut the
lights off real fast but I've already
seen that there's it's full of people so
I tell them hey stop right here stop the
car right here right in front of the
building let me in right here so they're
like okay okay okay okay but as soon as
we actually pull up to the neighborhood
the girl that was been sleep playing
sleep she all of a sudden but she's
she's awake like she's all she's fully
alert and everything and um so I say let
me out here so I'm kind of I'm kind of
hip to what get ready going so I go up
to the building it's one of these
buildings where the door locks behind
you so I go up I'm going up the steps
I'm going up the steps as soon as I'm
going up the steps I'm looking down
these big glass windows I see all the
guys running from the truck now they're
running down trying to get open to the
door so I'm like oh okay so I know it's
going to okay so it's it's two ways
they're going to get in I'mma let them
in or these girls going to let them in
so what I do is I take my bag mind you
there's nothing in my bag because
everything's already here at the stash
house I'm just coming for a funeral so I
have my bag which is just full of
clothes and I take it and I prop open
the door um of the building um not the
building of the actual uh apartment and
same thing as the apartment is the same
thing as the building as soon as the
apartment closes it locks behind you so
I prop the door open and I actually go
downstairs and open the door for them I
go open door for them and surprise them
they're like whoa what the and they
we're all now we're all tussling we're
all tussling it's like four of them um
we're tussling we're tussling one of
them runs breaks upstairs grabs grabs
the bag that's actually popping the door
open and he runs back downstairs and
he's just yelling I got I got everything
I got everything I'm just thinking in my
head like okay healing his clothes you
know healing his clothes so before that
dude hits me in the head with a gun I'm
like oh [__] um so but we're still
tussling then they all run out and
they're all still still um in their a
car so what I do is I run up to the
building I run up to the building cuz
they don't have my keys I still have my
keys I run up to the the apartment I go
up there grab the bulletproof vest grab
the gun and now now it's a okay Coral
out there so I run downstairs and I'm
lighting I light their car up they're
driving off I'm shooting at their car
and so what happens when I do that is
the girls now the girls are coming back
the girls are coming back acting
surprised I'm yelling at them because I
know they had something to do with it
but um I guess the whole time when I was
doing that and I ran outside the
neighbors called the police and said
there's a guy outside with a bulletproof
vest shooting at
people yo and he just went into that
apartment so while I'm sitting here
yelling at the I'm yelling at the um
girls I'm yelling at the girls I'm
calling some of my homeboys that's out
there I'm like yo you guys need to get
here now get here now get here now um
yelling at the girls yelling at the
girls um and uh next you know I'm
looking out the windows and I see red
and blue on out of every window cuz
these have Windows that go all around
from Back to Front side side everywhere
I look just red and blue red and blue
red and blue I'm like oh [__] uh oh and
then um I actually still have the vest
on right and I'm like oh [__] I can't if
they see me with a vest onor they're
goingon to try to shoot me and that's
why I'm already thinking so I try I'm
getting ready to go to the front door as
I'm going to the front door I hear them
coming up the front door I'm like uh oh
now they're coming directly to the door
and then they go boom boom they're now
they're just trying to kick it in
they're just trying to kick it in Kick
It In and then as soon as they do get
the door in boom they kick it in guns
are
blazing I'm like oh [__] so I actually
jump out the window so when I jumped out
the window mind you this is Maryland
this is like uh I think this was in this
was February as matter of fact it was
February 15th um there was snow in the
back there was no snow in the front
that's the craziest thing there was no
snow in the front so I go and when I
jumped in the back it was full of snow
my foot went right into the snow and
cracked right over yeah it just cuz I
jumped I jumped what uh like five
stories so it just landed it went into
the snow and cracked over cracked over
I'm like oh [__] and mind you I have so
before I did all this too I threw the I
threw all the weed out out the window
all the money no actually I left the I'm
tripping I left the weed in I threw all
the guns out the window cuz I had the
house was full of guns so I put them all
d bag you jumped out of a f story window
yeah but I threw the guns first I threw
all the cash with me so I had a big Duff
bag full of cash and duffel bag full of
guns so now on the ground I'm on the
ground and now I'm just crawling in the
snow with two duffel bags and my uh my
boy's calling now cuz he's he's now he's
getting he's he's getting closer but I
can't answer the phone cuz it's so wet
it's so wet I can't answer the phone I
can't answer the phone I'm like [__] it
won't answer it won't answer I'm just
like [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] it won't
answer and then I'm just I'm just
dragging myself dragging myself just
slowly dragging myself dragging myself I
look I can look back and I see them
inside the apartment I can see all the
police in the apartment they can't see
me and the craziest thing I look over I
also see the neighbor the neighbor's
looking out the window they're looking
out the window and supposedly like after
I read all the police report this is
also the neighbor that called the police
that with the initial call yeah so
they're looking out the window and they
even call the police again and say he's
actually out in the back so while I'm
crawling I'm crawling I'm crawling I'm
crawling now I see them coming around
the side of the building with all their
flashlights I'm like oh [__] so I'm
trying to crawl into under a car I throw
one bag under one car with the guns I
throw I I keep the money bag with me I
was like [__] this so I keep the money
with me I'm crawling I'm crawling I'm
crawling I'm crawling and they don't see
me they go way over here I'm looking at
them they go way over here they're not
even nowhere near me I'm like oh my
goodness play they don't see me and at
the same exact time my boy is pulling in
so now he's pulling in now I see his car
coming and he's coming I said oh yes I'm
saved but they stop him they stop him
boom they stop him and I said oh [__]
and he has guns all on his front you
know on his front seat cuz he's coming
he's coming ready for war and um they
stop him they ask him yeah what are you
doing he tells them oh well my some dude
try to rob my cousin and so this is like
oh so you're part of what we're actually
looking for so they arrest him yeah and
I'm watching this whole thing and then
as they arrest him I see them slowly
start walking my Direction with the
flashlights I'm like oh [__] and I can't
crawl like I can't go anywhere my leg is
done um it's just done and so what
happens then they find me they they ask
me my name I'm not telling them I'm like
yo my leg every time they ask me my name
I'm just like my leg my leg my leg and
so they pick me up and they see my leg
just hanging like this just dangling
they're like oh [__] and so they call
the ambulance they this is God this is
how God works so they lock me up right
to the to the um to the stretcher I'm
locked up to the stretcher I have to go
to emergency
surgery and so the police are actually
arguing with the uh at the hospital
they're arguing with the people at the
hospital they're like you have to keep
them uh handcuffed because of what just
happened but the surger the the hospital
hpit tell him we have to take the
handcuffs off to do the surg there's no
way we could do the surgery with the
handcuffs and so literally these are
these are the last words I hear from the
cop he tells this lady he says you know
what lady when he gets out of this
surgery you better call me cuz I'mma
lock his ass up right so I go to the
surgery you know I go out I'm on
anesthesia I go out I actually wake up
and I have all the bars through my leg I
have all the bars through my leg my my
name actually says John Doe on my um
wristband the lady comes back in and she
says this
here's a
wheelchair go now the police are coming
you better go now yeah she let you go
yeah she said you better find a way but
go now and I was like oh [__] what the
[__] what do you mean like cuz I still
don't like now I'm kind of like confused
I'm like hold on what the [__] just like
and um she like just go so I make a
phone call they come pick me up and I
actually go from Maryland to DC now so I
go into the DC hospital I just roll into
the DC hospital with all the bars and
stuff in my leg I just go in there and
say look I didn't have any Insurance the
Maryland they just kicked me out they
left the bars in my leg and they kicked
me out cuz I don't have insurance I need
help look it's ble like it's blood
leaking everything they're like what the
[__] what there's no way they just like
I'm like yes trust me I didn't have
insurance just just help me they were
like oh [__] no so they actually and I
end up getting all the surgery from
there so they so they did the surgery as
if you know I just got kicked out with
you know and um so then the H the the
police keep going to the hospital
they're going to the hospital looking
for me they're going to the first
hospital they're they're trying to
figure out what the hell happened you
know and so after I did the surgeries in
DC um I called my boys from San
Francisco I said you guys got to come
get me I can't be here because this is
all bad so they drive uh uh they drive
the truck down and I literally have a
pick line and um IVs I have IVs on one
side like just like this I have a pick
line just like this like from the
hospital and they take me out and I'm in
freaking SUV and we ride from DC to San
Francisco with those shits in in me and
the pick line goes through my heart yeah
so we're riding all the in the truck
escap another hospital basically and
yeah and it's crazy when I get to San
Francisco this whole trip it was fine as
soon as I get to San Francisco the pick
line actually comes out of my heart like
it just slides out and I'm like oh [__]
and all the blood just starts coming
down I'm like what the [__] yo
yeah crazy did you ever get caught by
the cops oh so here we go so for this
case um so now I'm back in San Francisco
so I'm back in San Francisco and um I'm
doing it now like okay I got to go do
more surgeries at San Francisco General
so because I had to do so many surgeries
and it's just me leaving so many
hospitals was really complicating a lot
of [__] there and I have to make up a
new story of why like uh yo why the hell
did this just let you out with the bars
why are you this this this and you
didn't do therapy it's just so I'm in
San Francisco they make me an inpatient
because I'm a resident in San Francisco
so they make me an impatient at the
hospital so I'm at the
hospital uh probably about five five six
months now I'm talking about I'm a real
resident at this hospital I have friends
here I have I have I know everybody here
one day at the in the morning um because
also San Francisco General uh being that
it was a public hospital they have
sheriffs that actually stay in the
hospital at all times so one day he
literally said he was bored and just ran
my name yeah he's like I was just bored
so I just ran your name because you you
know you're just always here because
you're here so he said I ran your name
and then I saw all the [__] so then they
waited till I um they waited till they
gave me an IV like a like they gave me a
morphine IV so I was knocked I was like
whoa and then next you know I just hear
the handcuffs everywhere I'm like what
the [__] is going on they're like yeah
and they pull up a picture from Maryland
they say look this is
you you know uh three this is now um
about two years have passed too like
this is you from two years ago they've
been looking for you this is this this
this we're taking you back um well we're
going to see if they want to take you so
they took me to 850 Bryant which is the
San Francisco county jail so now I'm
sitting in San Francisco
County uh with still halfway through
surgeries and I'm like yo what the [__]
like what the hell's going on so and
then um so they gave them like 60 days
to pick me up you know what Maryland
does Maryland literally waits for the
60th day to come and get me they come
and get me on that 60th day transfer me
on a plane still [__] up you know and
taking me to Maryland I sit in Maryland
for 9 months fighting the case and um
you know we just brought the best
lawyers and we end up getting a a plea
deal of just a possession of a firearm
uh while trafficking that was it yeah
yep and took the time
served yeah pretty good yeah and just
had to register like as a gun offender
what year was that that was
13 mhm yeah crazy
yeah things have changed a lot in the
Pod game oh yeah yeah for sure for sure
yep heck
yeah yeah and then um yeah like I said
that's how that's why we have no ankle
and I tell people all the time like it's
crazy CU technically I never was ever
supposed to walk that's the thing about
being in the Maryland jail too so like I
said I was going through all those jails
stealing Wheelchairs and all this stuff
when I got to the Maryland jail because
they really hated me what they did they
took the wheelchair away
and they took the cane away and no
actually they took the wheelchair away
and gave me a cane that's what they did
and I'm like what the [__] I can't use a
cane I don't I can't walk you know what
I'm saying and so they were basically
forcing me trying to force me to walk
and so my Sy he's like [__] bro we're
going to have to learn to walk and
that's literally how I learned to walk
was me and my Sy every day getting up
with the cane him holding me me walking
every like he literally taught me how to
walk back again just the craziest thing
yeah we were just every day every day
with the cane every day with the cane
and then I would go do the hospital
visits and they were like hold on what
the hell like there's no ankle there
like there's no way you should be
walking you should be in your wheelchair
I'm like look we
walking we're not doing the wheelchair
thing for life we're going to walk yeah
yep what's what's it like living that
that lifestyle of a drug
Smuggler
honestly you know it's always going to
be fun when you uh when it's in the
moment you know the good times is always
good the bad times is always bad like
this yeah but honestly too if you're
doing it right like even when I was um
let's say when I had to go to jail me
doing it right on the streets always had
money to where I would go to jail and
have a I'd have 10 people commissaries
paid for so I know I was always good no
matter what jail I went to I've been to
11 different counties in 11 different
County jails um I did the count the
other day I was like how many county
jails have I been to I've been to 11
different County jails and different all
different cities um so it's like and
it's awful we you you traffic it you
know um and it's
just yeah but I always made sure we were
good yeah from Collinsville Illinois to
to Yum Arizona which is probably the
craziest stories ever um
to what I just told you you know it just
we always made sure we were
good and always met some good solid
people you got out of that when it
became
legalized uh for for for the Maryland
case well just just when when Pop became
less of a so n Maryland Maryland still
wasn't legalized really it was just a
good lawyer that got me you know out of
that um I think Maryland just became
legalized two years ago oh is it right
yeah they they're recent yeah they're
they're very recent with it um yeah
Illinois same way they're like two three
years with it honestly if my case pulled
up four or five years ago they probably
would have arrested me you know
Collinsville would have took that case
on but it's because it just passed they
were kind of like bro you know it's like
yeah he's just gonna fight it probably
win and if he does lock if we do lock
him up he probably get out soon it's
just kind of point they're gonna waste
more time trying to you know just try to
fight me and try to do the case so it's
like yeah just whatever what have you
done since
then um of course I'm a music manager
but uh of we caught more drug
trafficking
cases you know y Arizona um probably one
of the biggest cases in y Arizona to
this day I know they say we had one of
the longest uh border patrol chases me
and my girlfriend which is crazy who I'm
still with to this day Third Day me of
her meeting me she had to go on a border
Patrol Chase
so it was a crazy one yeah tell me about
that um so
basically uh this is when I was actually
living in San Diego so I was living in
San Diego and um I used to have crazy
crazy crazy amounts going on in Texas
Texas is one of those spots where if you
want to make some money money you go to
Texas Florida those those spots and so
Texas um I'm taking get ready to take a
load down to Texas and I asked her I say
you want to go down in Houston you know
I got a house down in Houston we got you
know we're just chilling go see my
friends this this I don't tell her the
car is loaded you know I say go this is
also why she's banned from Enterprise
for life so I tell her to go rent a car
so she go rinse the car from Enterprise
um and we hit the road
and ways I don't like you for this one
because
I put Houston Texas in from San Diego
and what Wes made me do was go through
it was trying to make me go through
Mexico and so as we're driving we're
driving cars loaded you know we're just
driving I've taken this I've done I've
done the route so many times I'm just
not paying attention but ways this time
says we're going through Mexico and as I
look up I see Last Exit to
USA I look at her I said last ex
USA I keep driving you know I keep
driving the next you know I see all the
border patrol lined up and I'm like what
the [__] I've never seen this on this
like on the route before maybe it's like
just you know a random checkpoint but
then it was actually the Yuma Arizona
border checkpoint as I'm getting closer
getting closer the dogs are already
going crazy they're barking they're
barking they're barking barking they're
trying to they're already trying to jump
at the car jump at the car I'm like oh
[__] and so as I get closer get closer
they're like secondary you go to
secondary I look at them look at her I
said we gone
she's like oh well let's go so we go um
as soon as we do that look back they all
run into their cars they run to the cars
they right behind me I make the first
exit I hit the first exit and and it's
pitch black too so we hit the first exit
we get out the car I said come on let's
go we get out now we're on foot and this
is probably the craziest thing I wish
she was here to tell you this so we're
out on foot and literally we're in the
desert so we're running we're running
running the first three minutes we're
running we're running we hit like
probably over like a 10 20 feet drop
like we're roll I'm talking about we we
rolling rolling rolling rolling in the
dirt and everything so you left the pot
in the car yeah we just left in the car
but we parked in somebody's driveway
literally so we drive the car we like as
soon as we get off the exit it was full
of houses so I parked in somebody's
driveways park right at somebody's
driveway get out and we we're gone so
but the crazy thing as soon as we run it
was a drop straight down we both Dro and
we're rolling I'm like oh [__] we're
rolling we're rolling we're rolling
rolling and now we're in the real Yuma
desert we're in the desert now and um so
we're in the desert and we're just I
told her let's go so I start to see that
I now see the cars starting to hit the
exit they hitting the exit um all the
cop cars so we're just we're just going
forward all you can do is see and you
can't see nothing you literally it's
Pitch Black it's pitch black every
couple steps you run it's barbwire so
we're running we're running we're
running we're hitting
barbwire we see you have openings of
barbwire so you can calll through I have
a backpack on we have to put it on top
to get over um so we hit the bar we hit
the first set of Barb Wire they realized
we're not in the car because after we
probably got about I would
say honestly we probably ran for about
45 minutes to an hour before they even
started to come to the woods this this
Woods was deep I mean it was big so I
would say 45 minutes to an hour we're
already in there we're in there I'm
telling her we got to get to Mexico you
know like we get to the across the
Mexico border we cool we'll be all right
we'll figure it out over there get them
some cash you know I got cash in my
pocket we'll just try to look we just
made it over we from America we're just
trying to party for the night Bo you
know we from Arizona you know and so
we're just running we're running running
we going through but you literally can't
see anything so you don't know which way
to go you don't know which way to go
like everything is just pitch black
everything is pitch black so we're
running for an hour and literally as as
we start running then we start to see
lights for a highway I'm oh [__] we're
getting somewhere see Mexico we're still
we're still going to be in Arizona you
know what I me I don't know if we're
going back to where we came from like
you you can't you just don't know and so
we're running we're running we're
running we're starting to go closer
closer Closer Closer as we starting to
get now you start to hear the dogs like
the dogs are in they're in the woods too
so we start to hear the dogs we start to
hear the dogs we're hearing at we're
hearing the ATVs we're like oh [__] like
um but as we would start to run the dog
at one point the dogs got real close we
hit barb wire that was it you didn't
hear the dogs for a while so we hit the
barb wire we're gone we don't hear the
ATVs for a while um I'd say probably
another hour and a half we're still out
there it's cold too we're out there
we're out there we're still running
we're still running and the closer the
the highway looks it's still getting far
it's like yo we're not getting any
closer to this [__] we're like we're
running running trying to get to the
highway trying to get to the highway
we're not getting there we're not
getting there here comes the helicopters
oh [__] here comes the
helicopter it flies past once when it f
flies past the first time I told her I
said that's it I know like I watch
plenty of TV plenty of TV and I know
real life I know what that helicopter
got on there so when it did it it did it
the first time it comes back the second
time but what it does is it would it
flies way out like I mean it'll fly out
for actual like 20 minutes out then it
came back right right past us again and
flew another 20 minutes out and so I
told her I was like okay that second
time they're coming back so I was like
all right get on the ground and I'm
gonna get on top of you so it looks like
we're animals cuz I was like yo they got
heat they got the uh I know they got the
heat sensors on there they coming and so
what they do the second time the third
time is they do the same thing they do
the fly out but then they stop and when
they stopped they put that Spotlight on
and boom it was right there and but it's
craziest the craziest craziest thing is
when they put the spotlight on as soon
as we looked up the police were already
there they were so quiet they were that
quiet they literally creeped the whole
way creep the whole way creep the whole
way creep the whole way and when the
spotlight came on all we had to do was
turn around and they they were literally
right there we like what the [__] yo
hell oh hell you know they just they
going crazy draging us Dragon us Dragon
us they take us to
the one of the craziest craziest places
The Yuma Arizona um border patrol
station oh that's one of the worst
places ever I feel I feel for the
migrants that are there let me tell you
something they put everybody in silver
blankets they give you like these silver
blanket jumpsuits everybody's there were
piled up
I'm talking about I'm in the same cell
as
kids adults grandads it's all guys in
one but it's from kids on up you know
then you got the same thing with the
females the females kids on up because
it's all migrants in these border patrol
JS it's everybody in here and we're just
like literally they are stuffed it's
[__] everywhere it's stuff everywhere
all around it's [__] everywhere it's
piss like it's this [__] is crazy I'm
like yo no [__] way I'm yell at them
like yo I'm not a freaking migrant you
guys got to get me the [__] out of here
and so one of the craziest things too is
I had um I had uh I had uh I had TC oil
with me right and so I had wax TC oil
with me and they were trying to say that
was
heroin yeah so they were putting that on
the scale saying yeah no no no you're
trafficking heroin in marijuana I'm like
no no no no no no no this is not heroin
this is thhc they no no no no this is
heroin I'm like oh my [__] goodness
so my original charge from them was
actually heroin possession of heroin and
possession of marijuana you know with
the intent to distribute and I'm like oh
[__] no you guys are tripping you know
what I'm saying and then for my girl
they were trying to give her the same
thing but I just like no no she ain't
had nothing to do it you know it's mine
so they were like okay they let her go
they okay [__] it we'll let her go from
right here she's figure her own way let
her go we're GNA take you you know take
you to Y Arizona jail I went to the new
Arizona jail um I sat there for about
two weeks they gave me I I went to go
see see a judge he gave me a $250,000
bail
100% yeah no 10% no nothing you had to
pay whole 250,000 to the court I was
like God damn it okay so you know made
the phone call they they got everything
together um one cool thing I can say
about the um Arizona jail is they gave
you these little orange phones like it's
kind of like a cell phone so um because
like uh cuz I would had to go I had to
go on the medical unit because of my leg
so basically I have a phone in my sell
the whole time a little like a little
orange phone it's basically a cell phone
so I can use the phone all day all day
all day so I'm making the calls to get
the you know get the money happening and
um so when they finally get the money um
they you know they take they get me out
they bail me out and um yeah and I go to
court the craziest thing too when I go
to court for it I go to court for it
they say um well the police didn't show
up the police didn't show the police
didn't show up they like the police
didn't show up they so they didn't bring
anything so we don't have anything for
this case right now
um we're going to send you a date to
when to come back and they never ever
sent me a
date yeah that's the end of it yeah I've
been I've been I've been through locked
up I've been this since then it's never
popped up no nothing it's never been a
warrant no nothing it's crazy
yeah it's great yeah because the cops on
the show yeah yeah right I was like whoa
what the hell yeah yeah and then you
know from there it's just we kind of
transition to what I do now which is um
I would say probably one of the most
prominent and you know I call myself the
uh the millionaire middleman you know
from the middleman from the music
industry to the to the streets the as
far as the music industry goes you know
I'm the the man that's behind a lot of
people's careers you know from boozy
badass to Julio fulio to Freddy Gibbs to
Raven justice big baby Glenn Davis um
a lot of people you know how how did you
make that transition the craziest thing
was booie booie actually was the one
that made me the transition booie being
me and booie being so close um he kind
of helped me with the
transition from just going to the
streets cuz at the end of first um of
course everything we did was all Street
you know whether it's me bringing weed
to Atlanta me bringing weed to here
meing it's just just what is what it is
but um it kind of transition from there
to where he's like bro I could just put
you on with you know when they when they
call me to book a show I'm going just
tell them to call you so it's the
contacts you made selling weed yeah yeah
yeah me being me in the weed industry
like if I'm if I'm in North Carolina if
I'm in
Atlanta from any any City I touch I'm
I'm just going to be like I'm in San
Francisco I'm in DC like I'mma make you
know I'm going to go to the best club
we're going to spend the most money and
we're going to be in the best sections
we're going to make sure you know who
you know who's who you know and and I'm
not from around here you can tell I'm
not from around here so come on and see
what's going on you know and
relationships start like that and I feel
like weed is universal weed brings
everybody together and that's really how
it happened you know and um and from
there we just from just being being what
what he would consider his weed man to
his manager you know and from there
making a lot of connections um
and and me being in in California you
know it's
different uh uh uh this is the this is
the mecca for the entertainment you know
the entertainment industry so when I
make my connections there I also make my
own connections here and then I bring in
I Bridge those gaps together and um I've
been doing that for so long from whether
it's San Francisco whether it's La
whether it's Atlanta whether it's DC
Miami I just Bridge these little gaps I
Network I know how to network I know how
to talk you know
um and I put a lot a lot of deals
together you know and then I think that
just people see the the a lot of success
that I helped you know I had with boozy
um whether it's the brand deals whether
it's actual bookings you know and it
just kind of the clients kind of just
trickled in from there you know yeah and
then not not many stories not many
people make it out of the streets yeah
to to the yeah that's the thing too it's
like success story yeah that that's
that's another thing too I feel like
that's also why um a lot of people trust
me with their careers too you know cuz
of of the stuff I've been through you
know they know you know I was I'm the
one that's always in charge too and and
I think that's also how I get a I
acquire these good relationships with a
lot of big artists it's because in my
world I'm I'm up there too you know what
I'm saying in your world you're there in
my world I'm here so when we connect
it's you know it's just I don't look at
you you you know what I mean you're no
bigger than me you know that's how I
always see it and so even and that's why
I always me and my CL we're always good
friends you know I don't even look at
say people are my clients and stuff we
always friends you know what I mean just
yeah all all my
manager we're always we're just good
friends you know and I make it happen to
do some of the best best deals right now
like with Freddy Gibbs me and Freddy
Gibbs we've been going crazy we've been
going crazy from weed deals to comedy
shows to actual action figure toys to
deals with piston to I mean yeah
I don't stop and you've been doing this
for how long um the music industry I was
I'm going on probably about almost eight
years now in the music industry more fun
than the
weed uh yeah it's more fun than the weed
but you know the weed's still in the
music industry the good thing about that
too is a lot of my friends that uh
coming up being being what I was in the
weed industry became legal so a lot of
these people I know most of these weed
owners you know because of what I do
what I've been doing you know I know
burner I know uh uh I know Pat from cure
company you know I know these different
people because of what I've already done
in the streets so they're like oh you
know what I mean they just happen to go
to the legal side which I should have
did you
know you know they just turned it up a
whole another level is is it just as
lucrative now that it's legalized as it
was when it was illegal uh more because
you know these guys make millions and
millions out of these stores you
know yeah you can make millions in the
weed game but but the hardest thing is
is you make a million dollars in in in
in Florida the hardest thing is getting
it back to California you know I've
always had problems with that I remember
one time I was uh bringing
350,000 from DC to San Francisco on the
Greyhound and um we end up stopping in
Colorado that's where the stop was and
because you stop in Colorado and weed is
there the next stop was it was either
Salt Lake or mon Montana it was one of
those one of those two cities was the
next stop and what they did was they
searched the bus because of that pulled
everybody off to search the bus and I'm
like oh [__] this is about to be bad and
so what they also did they made they put
a stamp the police they they they
searched everybody's bags under the
thing and what you had to do was line up
and get your uh your P stamp to say that
you got searched and so when it came to
me so I had the money it's it's on me
right so I have it in um I have it in a
little duffel bag I'm like [__] and so
they're searching your person's bags and
your under your underc Carriage bags so
literally these two old ladies sitting
at the Greyhound station and so I just
walk next to them I sit there and I put
my bag right in between them 350,000
just sitting right with cash just sits
there and then they call me and they go
up yeah you have any bags I'm like no I
don't have any bags I'm just Bo I'm
traveling okay stamp my thing and I just
wait wait wait till they call the bus
and I don't touch my B I leave my bag
I'm just have my eye on it I'm like yo
these ladies better not touch this [__]
and so I'm just looking they don't never
touch the bag and then they call they
call the Greyhound it's time to go I'm
like oh [__] and I just wait run walk
slowly walk over to grab my bag and I
get on the bus they look at my P to see
I got searched so they think my bag is
searched and let me on the bus I'm like
oh my [__] goodness yeah there's a
lot of stress in that life oh yeah
that's the thing too yeah you know I
would rather just cuz I also owned a
dispensary that's the thing too so I
owned a dispensary in San Diego when I
lived in San Diego I actually owned a
dispensary yeah um one of the first
black people that own a dispensary in
San Diego that was one of
my very well titles I love to just
spread to the world you know one of the
first black owners of a dispensary in
San Diego but what happened was they
didn't want to renew my license after
they ran my background yeah they were
like hold up I don't even know how you
did the license in the first place but
yeah we can't renew this one but it was
a good run while you know that's and
that dispensary actually is what paid my
bail when I caught CU I owned the
dispensary when I caught the Arizona
case yeah so that was how I paid my bill
the 250,000 was the dispensary so that
also kind of answered the question there
the dispensary game is like you know I
was able to just go to dispensary like
yo I need the 250 out of dispensary well
are there are there things you learned
in that game that helps you now with the
music industry um yeah um like so so for
right now I like to consider myself a
shark you know you can only be two
things you could be a shark or a shrimp
right and so I think me being a shark in
the weed game helped me be a shark in
the music industry that's how I able to
acquire all these brand deals with all
these different companies you know know
um if I go in for a deal it's not going
to be for for just one little check no
we going in for a lifetime deal or we
ain't signing the deal you know you tell
me all my bookings are 15,000 okay I'm
GNA go tell them we getting we need
20,000 we're going to try to work it
from there I'm GNA get you more than
what you asked for you know it's just
got to be a shark and I think that
mentality translates from something like
smuggling weed to yeah another industry
yeah got to be you got to be you know
and be on being on point you know being
on point is one of the biggest things
you you know I think being on point
helped me stay alive a lot of times you
know I've been in shootouts and all
types of stuff like when you say being
on point you mean what um just knowing
your surroundings you know you always
got to know your surroundings and try to
be one step ahead of people knowing
what's up yeah yeah I've been in a I've
been in shootouts where I've actually
been in a shootout here in La you know
what I mean on Broadway where you
know stuff happens where luckily I'm
here you know what I'm saying but um
yeah people um I was leaving out of
Studio One Time and um this is the
craziest [__] so I'm leaving out studio
and we go to the spot I'm getting ready
to drop off some weed and I'm chilling
in front of my boy's house and car
passes okay car passes but it's the same
car that was just at the studio cuz
let's let's rewind this so I'm at at the
studio when I pull up to the studio
there's actually like this dark like
Volvo sitting at the studio couple guys
in there but it was tinted out but they
were still sitting in the car so when I
go into the studio I go into the studio
I'm showing some guys some weed I got
jewelry on and stuff
um I come out the studio and then I
leave so I leave out the studio now I'm
at my boy's house this is
like now say 10 20 minutes away from the
studio I leave we're out there for about
an hour standing out front next thing
you know that same car from the studio
passes but I didn't really think about
it the same car so it passes and then it
passes and then um it parks behind the
building so I don't really I don't know
this because you know the neighbor
started telling us this so it parks
behind the building as I'm walking to my
car so I'm walk into my car as soon as I
open my door two guys they're literally
behind my car they just pop up yo give
me all the jewelry I'm like oh [__] okay
I know what time this is but I have the
pistol on me so I'm like okay so as I'm
trying to as I'm doing this so what I do
is I take off I'm tring acting like I'm
taking off the chain with one hand
I'm like hold on hold on hold on so I'm
doing this and I just whip out and now
it's a shootout yeah and one of them
made it home one of them didn't you know
but at the end day a little self-defense
but um yeah the hood is rough yeah the
hood is rough and but the crazy thing
about that is so as I'm going home so we
leave I I leave out and this is the
crazy thing how they actually even knew
where I was so I go home and um I hit a
speed bump I hit a speed bump cuz this
is I'm driving my Coupe so I'm driving
my Coupe is low so I hit a speed bump
and I hear a ding I'm like what the [__]
is that and so it's loud too so then I
hit another speed bump now I hear it
again Ding and I'm like what the [__] so
then I park the car I look under my car
and there's a Tracker under my car I can
show you yeah I'll show you I still have
the picture yeah it's a GPS tracker
under my car I'm like oh [__] yeah so
they must have put it under under the
studio yeah and tried to follow me
yep wow yep an Amazon tracker at that
cuz I looked at it you buy this [__] on
Amazon for like
$15 but obviously that [__] worked
because they knew exactly where I was
yeah then the studio guy huh how long
you been in La so I moved from San Diego
to LA you know what's crazy so my name
my first name is actually Briant b r y n
t the day I was moving my bags from San
Diego to LA my phone was going crazy
because that's the same day Kobe Bryant
died and the helicopter M yeah yeah so
like four or five years ago y so when La
lost one Bryant they acquired another
one you know and did you live in the
hood then when I moved to LA I moved to
Korea Town yeah yeah Korea Town was cool
you know I I never see one thing about
me
um I've always been infatuated with the
streets at the end of the day the thing
about the difference between like LA and
The Bay is la is gang banging you know
the bay is always it's still street life
but the the the bay is more hustling and
pimping you know but it's still the
streets it still gets it still gets
grimy it still gets rough you know what
I mean so it's just a matter of where
streets you are and the same thing even
when I'm in Florida I'm in Jacksonville
I'm on Arlington Road in Jacksonville
Florida you know what I mean that's it
go it goes down so it's like even when
I'm in different cities I'm always in
the hoods I feel like it's not that
that's where I feel most comfortable
it's just you know that's where the
money's
at that's where the money is for you
that's where the money's at you know
that's where the you know that's where
they showing love you know I don't
really have problems in the I never
really had problems in the Hood um
because you know it's all about the
energy too you bring you know I always
go off Good Vibes Good Vibes and at the
end of the day it's like this I'm
supplying the hood you can't Rob the
suppli you rob the supplier I'm not
coming back [__] that you know what I'm
saying so [__] what's the point and
that's also why I have other people in
these places to make sure when I land
and I touch down that everything's okay
you know the the you know the red carpet
is laid out just as if you would have
came to California I would make sure the
red carpet is laid out so yeah all right
pmac interesting stories yes sir I'm
glad you're doing well now yes
appreciate that yes thank you man
appreciate
it
I